when Bob McDonald took over the VA in
2014 after the whole Phoenix scandal he
told 60 minutes he had to fire over a
thousand people you've already fired
more than that why was that necessary we
now have a new accountability law that
Congress gave us that the President
signed that allows us to move people out
quicker and easier who have deviated
from professional standards acceptable
professional standards or deviated from
the professional beliefs that we have
about who should be caring for veterans
and part of changing this organization
is making it clear that it is a true
privilege to be able to serve veterans
and if you're not adhering to those
standards you don't belong in the VA and
we're making that clear and we're moving
people out that frankly should have been
moved out years ago and you were
transparent about that we looked at the
list and but a lot of these actions seem
to affect low-level employees I mean
there were cemetery caretakers and
gardeners and Mail clerks and I mean
isn't the main concern getting rid of
the supervisors and directors well I
think it's both wherever we find that
people aren't adhering to what they
should be doing we're holding them
accountable I think recently at the
Washington DC VA I fired the head of the
VA they're not once but twice
because the first time they did it
before we had her accountability law the
judge made me take him back and so once
we got the accountability law passed and
I had more protections I fired him again
and I'm serious and I want people to
understand that we are not going to
tolerate people staying in the VA and
caring for veterans who don't belong
there that accountability legislation
you mentioned that was also intended to
stem retaliation against whistleblowers
yes but we've been talking to
whistleblowers across the country for
the past year who say they don't they
don't feel a difference that the
retaliation they face is as strong as
ever and may even be getting worse why
would that be why do you think
these whistleblowers feel threatened
they're trying to expose the problems
that you want to hear yeah and we do
want employees that see problems to tell
us about it we will not accept
retaliation so in each of those cases
where there are reports of retaliation
they are investigated and we'll hold
people accountable for that I
established a office of whistleblower
protection that reports directly to me
we've hired whistleblowers who work in
that office so they understand what the
problems the VA have been and they're
helping us now solve those problems and
correct the culture but this is a big
organization and it takes a while to
make these changes so I want people to
understand that we're not declaring the
problems of the VA over we have a lot of
work to do and it's going to take us a
while to correct the problems that have
taken decades to build up within the VA